and tonight we start with the kyle
ridden house verdict you see the media
has spent the last few weeks insisting
that none of the facts in the case
mattered to them the only important
thing was the color of rindhouse skin
let's just do the thought experiment
just imagine ridden house as a young
black teenager sonny if he were black
would he be free now no he wouldn't be
alive now imagine
if
kyle rittenhouse was an 18 or 17 year
old black kid well that's a different
issue with a gun and talk about that
right how would people feel
so let's talk about that see if the
liberal media were actual journalists
they wouldn't have to ask what if this
happened to a black man
we know look no further than the story
of andrew coffey iv
so instead let me do their job and tell
america what happened
in march of 2017 andrew coffey was
asleep in his home when a swat team
arrived with a search warrant for his
father when police detonate a flashbang
device before entering coffee woke up
thinking he was being robbed being a gun
owner coffey opened fire looking to
defend his home
when police returned fire andrew's
girlfriend
arteria woods was tragically caught in
the crossfire and killed by police
now each side claimed the other shot
first but it was coffey who was
eventually charged with second-degree
murder and three counts of attempted
murder of law enforcement
after more than four years of legal
proceedings coffee name was cleared on
friday when he was found not guilty of
murder and attempted murder charges
coffey was still found guilty of weapon
possession charges and will face
sentencing for that but here's the
important part
that decision came down the same day as
the ridden house verdict and yet
everyone on the left chose to ignore it
and you have to ask yourself why well we
know that's because andrew's coffee
story doesn't fit into their narrative
liberals want you to think that white
people can get away with literal murder
while there's no justice for a black man
in america
that the court system will go out of his
way to destroy a black man with a gun
but andrew coffey's story blows up that
entire narrative so they chose to just
ignore it
the left wants to paint black americans
as victims and say they don't believe in
the second amendment or self defense
but we know that's not true we've been
defending ourselves and our homes for
years
now according to the national shooting
sports foundation from 2019 to 2020
there was a
58.2
increase in gun purchases among black
people so as more and more black
americans arm themselves andrew's coffee
story once again goes against the left
narrative he was a black man with the
gun defending his home and the justice
system cleared his name the same as they
did for kyle rittenhouse
but that didn't matter to the media
they're too busy trying to disarm black
america so they just ignored andrew's
coffee story
color blind justice doesn't move the
outrage needle for the left
but racism does
they left profits by dividing america by
race and they don't care about the
damage they're doing hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else